[Musique]
vous kelly vous avez un truc si vous
avez peur que la dame blanche
oui énormément depuis le collège depuis
des années avec les copines c'était la
dame blanche
on va rappeler c'est quoi la dame
blanche c'est une apparition que ceux
sur des routes ou dans une forêt et qui
est une apparition évidemment surnaturel
et qui normalement ne porte pas bonheur
alors les chéris n'ont pas démarré
l'émission phare ça ce soir juste dans
un instant on va recevoir jean luc
bertrand vous allez voir qu'il va faire
un truc fou à benjamin castaldi
mais juste avant agathe et kelly vous
avez été je peux aller à côté de télé
pour regarder
pour l'instant vous rester là agathe et
kelly vous étiez parti on vous a fait
croire que vous alliez faire une soirée
un gala à la parité à la et ce gars là
ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
regardez c'est parti sai baba normal
activity on est en direct ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ça
merci vous allez bien et donc vous
travaillez pour l'émission télé ça c'est
l'émission sympa sans connaître reviens
moi ça comme ça c'est fait vous êtes
capitanat je croyais bien faire
franchement là le chemin on va
maintenant là où va le monde
mais où va notre [ __ ] de société mère
gm cherche au pire il ya un peu de route
effectivement d'accord
[Musique]
ça risque de prendre un tout petit peu
plus de temps soit ils enfermaient la
n104 là on est parti
[Musique]
un psychopathe marque je suis je suis
très choqué non a priori juste je
conduis chaque métier ce but là
nous approchons rendement
nous mettons ce site du coup sûr le
château d'angoissé
[Musique]
pour le moment là
c'est qu'on trouve à arriver chez
centraide
non
non mais quelle angoisse
mon dieu mais je suis pas engagé 1 / h
plus son sillage en
dans ma culotte et immédiatement quoi
mais c'est des chemins de même cadeau ni
ça c'est pas référencer les salles
ça me fait tout nouveau cas mais vous
savez c'est juste quelqu'un sur le bord
de la route
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
on va
non
juste avant la naissance
mais pas du tout je sois patiente ul
tardivement par an j'ai du mal
qu est ce qu il faut que j'aille de tout
bois
dépose un peu plus loin mais je crois
qu'à un village juste après tout je
dépose juste après et vous allez où
exactement ce que j'avais tout droit
vous déposez
je sais pas si vous regarder devant vous
s'il vous plaît
nature droit ok j'ai compris qu'on va
aller tout droit jusqu'au tout droit
jusqu'au bout
on est à on a cinq
inquiétez pas je joue
débat autour de moules et wav et l'air
froid je le verrai ce que vous voulez un
téléphone qui je sais même pas par les
mérites la nouvelle à l'hôpital je pense
que je peux être quelqu'un qu'on va
peut-être y aller à pied nous rien c'est
un jour je sais pas c'est quoi ça que je
sais c'est pas regarder ça marche pas
médaille à bien regarder
j'éteins c étant ici je peux riche peut
rien faire attention à l'enfant
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît regardez là tout va bien
on est sur le lange jour où la trentaine
d'anciens enfants y'a pas d'emporter
garcia je vais faire ça tout est pensé
[Musique]
j'ai fait attention à la banque car il
n'y a pas d'enfant
[Musique]
tant pis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
anthony shadid yonne
ge capital
or
[Applaudissements]
le comédien et la marque paul le guen et
la famille elle aussi formidable
bravo à vous à l'écurie est la danoise
est vanessa était fabuleuse la dame
blanche hopper ma vie j'ai plus de voix
depuis ça fait toujours mais il ya eu ça
il ya eu çà et là meilleure phrase pour
moi de tout le truc c'est la meuf
c'est une le faut a fait j'ai fait je
crois que c'est la clim
c'est la meilleure phrase d'un gâteau
proue de l'histoire des phrases je crois
que c'est la clé c'était exceptionnel
franchement elle a trop travaillé
est ce que vous m'avez insulté bada
connard ont déplu au début connaît bien
après aussi a pas du tout pas du tout et
vous non pas du tout non non vous restez
c'était rigolo après mais sur le coup
j'ai vraiment la part des malades mais
vraiment il y était tellement tu es
vraiment à me demander de monter sur
elle pour la nourriture rct a gagné sur
moi je la porte on aurait dû mettre
maxime gagné avec vous bravo
[Applaudissements]